hello everyone
i'm christy jewell of labyrinths and i
would like to welcome you to today's
live broadcast
advanced quantitative fluorescence
microscopy
to probe the molecular dynamics of viral
entry
presented by dr luis alvarez product
application manager functional imaging
at leica microsystems today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by lab roots
and sponsored by leica microsystems for
more information on our sponsor
you can click on the logo on the left
side of your screen or visit
leica dash microsystems.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we will answer your questions at the end
of the presentation
additionally you can share today's
webinar on your personal social media
just click on that social sharing tab to
the left and let your friends and
colleagues know about today's live event
today's presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
at the conclusion of this webinar click
on the ce credits tab
located at the top of your screen and
follow the process
to obtain your credits now if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on that support tab down at the
top right of your presentation window
or you can use that ask a question box
to let us know you're experiencing a
problem
i would now like to introduce today's
presenter dr luis
alvarez product application manager
functional imaging
at leica microsystems for a complete
biography
on our speaker please visit the
biography tab
at the top of your screen welcome dr
alvarez
you may now begin your presentation
okay thank you everyone for listening
and
uh let's see if we can look a little bit
at
viral entry and how we can uh have a
little bit more insight
into some of the molecular events that
facilitate
uh all of these uh my contact
information
is on the screen and please feel free to
contact me
and if you have additional questions
after our questions and answers
at the end now i'm going to start with
uh
some generalities about confocal
microscopy and viral research and then
we'll uh spend the rest of your time
looking at
uh two really nice paper from uh
the sergio padilla lab in oxford uh
where
i was based before joining leica so
uh first thing is uh
something that uh in french would like
to say the guard foo or sanity tags for
experimental setups
and this actually can be applied for
host pathogen
in general not only viral research but
also bacteria
and this is the first concentrate on
what is your biological question
what is the hypothesis that you would
like to prove or disprove
and from there actually choose an
infection model this is
very important because only once you
have defined this
then you can look at what is the best
imaging approach that will fit not only
the model but that
it will actually allow you to answer the
question
we will see one of the examples today
that sometimes
perhaps the best way to answer the
question is not readily available
and so you have to come up with
additional work or just make it happen
now something very important for
imaging is you need to always verify
the infectivity of your virus always
control this is the most important thing
you want to make sure that
whatever things you are observing
are really part of the infectious
process
in a similar way you also want to ensure
that you have a minimal disruption to
your host
the cells have to react as natural as
possible
and to reiterate what you would expect
to happen
later or during an infection if you want
to be able to extrapolate some
of your data to more complex
models or even animal infection models
now um one thing that
is uh really nice with the confocal
microscope is you have optical
sectioning
and the virus sizes uh range from around
20 to 400 nanometers and
without this optical section and it is
quite difficult to
uh resolve them uh you can see actually
some
sizes of some common viruses today i
will concentrate on hiv
which has uh an approximate size about
120 nanometers
now even if you're concentrating on the
whole response to the viral infection
uh even then you uh it will be
suitable to actually look at the viruses
because otherwise
it's almost impossible to differentiate
the biological response that comes from
uh cell to cell
uh communication and from the actual
infection process and to be able to
actually
look at intervention strategies from the
viral response there now i just want to
recapitulate a couple
of uh classical things that we can do
with confocal imaging
and uh these are first to be able to
ascertain the special distribution of
single viral particles in different
components
either on fixed or live cells and the
second one is because of
this capacity to look at the special
distribution is to
be able to localize dividing particles
with other cellular components
protein complexes and so forth and this
also if done in life cell allows us to
also probe dynamics of
the infection process this is really
important because
it is a way to keep track of
the sequence of events that lead to any
given phenotype
and lastly we can really look at the
interplay between
the host components and the viruses and
have a chance to
look at what are the key aspects that
can either facilitate
or prevent such infections
now today i will be
talking to you those examples that are
based on hiv one
and so i thought it would be important
to recapitulate uh
some aspects of the hiv virus
you can see here uh a figure that is
part of a review we published
uh in 2017. uh i'm happy to
look at this this is on the whereabouts
of hiv v1 cellular entry and exclusion
ports
and uh it really goes over all of the
details of
uh the entry that were relevant at time
now one of the key aspects here is you
can see in the bottom that we have an
immature hiv
particle here all of the components
are present but these particles cannot
in fact
do to two things one is that uh the gag
proteins in the middle the
uh proper ones have not been yet cleaved
without these actually the macho guy
lattice
prevents the motility of the envelope
outside and
this inability to move these spikes
make these particles non-infectious
the other thing is uh these envelope
glycoproteins that we see here
in green are key for any infection
this is a really nice aspect because one
they define the tropism so
the kind of cells that they can infect
but two also we can generate
particles that are completely devoided
of the envelope glycoprotein
and hence we can have an able to control
in which we have
viral particles that are 100
non-infectious
now something nice about hiv is there
has been a lot of work done and
it's possible today to target with
fluorescent proteins to be able to
visualize it directly
one is on the gut proteins so if you mix
some tag and non-tag deck proteins
you can actually visualize that i have
actually
throughout my talk uh given some
references to papers that you can read
if you're interested in learning more
about these things here's one from uh
sergey padilla he was with greg melikan
on
gag gfp but uh
a little a couple years after that
actually
from the matsuda lab came out a really
nice paper in which they were
able to actually tag the envelope
glycoproteins
these are very specific
tags in some of the groups with super
folded gfp that allow you to still have
a particle that is infectious
nevertheless would attack spike which is
really nice
additional work has been done even
before this on
hiv virus in which we can have fusion
reporters
this is a really nice work that allows
you to have a better lactamase
uh
cleaving protein together with the vpr
so this means that actually once the
virus infects a cell
and crosses then the membrane
it releases this metallocamas and you
can have a fair reporter i will
talk a little bit more about this later
on today
okay so let's dig into our first
question and this is the effects of cell
metabolism
on the hiv entry
so here we can see uh some cells these
are tdmdl cells that have a reporter a
fred reporter
and you may be able to see some of the
viral particles well although you have
our particles
in numerous cells only fonts growing up
in red are
actually have been infected
so there's something quite interesting
when you're doing hospital
research is that in time
you may get all cells to be infected but
when you look
at time zero time one and two
you will see that actually uh in fact
the infection does not happen
all at once but you have a heterogeneity
of infections not all cells are infected
at the same time
and with the same amount
this basically yields kind of a patchy
result at first and this actually has
some
interesting implications he says that
there are some cells that are more
likely than others to infect
if you have put the viruses
in all cells at the same time and these
suggest that
there could be some natural sensitivity
to infection
and also some natural resistance to
infection
so uh we actually were discussing this
with sergi
when i joined him in oxford uh
we thought that it would be really nice
to have a way to look at this and this
was
uh some of the starting points
to come up with a really nice project
that ended up
on the paper i will present today now
from this we had an opportunity we knew
that the differences
in infectivity or resistance are not
genetic because all of these cells are
the same so
it means that there are factors that can
determine this resistance or sensitivity
and this has to be linked to something
else and we hypothesize that these
changes could be
due to metabolism so uh
i will show you uh first that this is
the case
so and then we will see how uh true
image and we can actually decipher the
mechanisms that are underlying it
so here we see actually a percentage of
infection in cells and we can see that
when we add
to the oxyglucose to uh basically
disrupt
uh the metabolism of the cells would
increase
dg then we have a decrease in infection
so this actually shows that there's a
reduction in hiv 1
vsbg envelope when we're trying to
infect mt4 t
cells with an increasing dose of two
dioxide glucose
mt4 t cells actually behave
metabolically and
uh for infection course purposes
just like cd4 plus t cells
so uh again i will touch on some
of the key experiments shown in this
paper
that was published earlier this year but
i'll invite you to
go and read for all of the details and
to have a complete view
of what has been published
okay here we can see uh now
a set of images in which we have first
uh
just cells with vehicle with without
any treatment in the princess of hiv
grfl these cells have a reporter that
allows us to see fusion
and here the fusion positive cells are
in red
and fusion negative are in green
and we can see that when we increase the
doses of 2d oxide glucose actually the
percentage of red
over green actually decrease and we can
see it here
on the graph here so this is with
tc mdl cells that are reporter cells
that allow us to actually
look at fusion directly so we wanted to
actually
understand exactly what is the process
that is happening here
and for this actually we did a
multiplex experiment in which we are
going to combine
a couple of tools first we have cell
sculptor with
gridded coverslips this is very
important because it allows us to
actually
be able to trace back the cells that we
have image
over time and these cells will actually
have a magnetically encoded biosensor in
this case
percival that actually allows us to
measure the ratio of
atp or adp and we're going to do that
with fluorescence lifetime
imaging uh again i will not go on
the details of fluorescent lifestyle
imaging today uh there is
a lot of literature on these and uh
there's
actually a webinar also on the basics of
flim that
i'd give you if you're interested now
these will allow us to see what is the
metabolism
of the cells before infection we will
add
viral particles of hiv and then actually
what these cells will allow us to do
also is
uh between 12 and 24 hours later
with excel assay to be able to tell
which of these cells
have been infected and then we can
correlate actually
what was the metabolism of the cell
before infection
and whether it got infected or not
so this looks like so you see uh on top
you have the these mdl
cells with percival looking at the
atp or adp ratio and in the bottom
the ones without laconic acid reporter
with the same rationale so we can see we
can here determine with the excal which
of the cells
uh have been infected and we can then
trace back each one of the cells through
their
uh presence lifetime imaging
parameters and from these we can
actually build these graphs at the end
and we can see that actually the
infection positive cells have
both a higher atp to adp ratio
and a higher lactate concentration so
this confirms that
the cells that actually exhibit higher
metabolism to begin with
are the ones that are more most likely
to be infected
down the road now
this is a little bit uh
difficult as an acid because you have to
wait until the infection process has
taken place 12 to 24 hours later
so uh we decided to do another multiplex
experiment and so this is all of the
work from
uh chad the psg student in the lab
and uh in this case again
use the same biosensors reservoir or the
glaconic acid biosensor
but this time actually multiplexed it
with a fret
biosensor for fusion it's called an
iblind fusion
versus fusion and in this case actually
uh
we have the vpr one of the viral
proteins
inside of the hiv that is linked to a
beta lactamase
so whenever the cell as i said before
crosses the membrane then it will have
the ability to cut
this dye that has been loaded into the
cells
and so in the presence of vpr blood
then the threat is disrupted and we can
actually tell
that that cell has been infected
so in this case uh
the interesting part is that we can uh
have
uh better timing on or
on the readout of diffusion compared to
the metabolism so we don't have to wait
multiple hours
after the fact to find out whether a
cell
has actually seen a fusion event
so we can see some of the images here so
on top we can see actually
again degraded slides with the cells
and if we see a blowout of these in the
glam you can see that you have
either the red or the
green cells and this is a threshold that
says up
which cell has been infected or not and
at the same time we can do
our fluorescence selection imaging and
in this case
we can have the readout on a cell by
cell basis and
recapitulate what is happening here we
can see that
this correlates nicely with the
infection process that we saw with the
x-val
that relatively high
collected concentrations compared to the
non-infected cells
and this is statistically significant
so what we have seen so far is that
this seems to be a preference for high
metabolism
uh for hiv to infect cells
it does not mean that the ones that
exhibit lower metabolisms do not get
infected
but uh it's just the probability of
infection is higher
with increased metabolism here
so i'm going to now
switch to another really nice experiment
that
was performed here and this is actually
uh continuing in this direction of what
now is the link between changing
metabolism and the ability
to infect what is actually changing that
will affect directly the viral entry and
one of the hypotheses here is that the
metabolism
could have some effects on uh
some of the lipid structures and the
membrane
specifically on cholesterol and
the amount of cholesterol in the
membrane and
changing with the metabolism will change
actually the fluidity on the membranes
and
directly affect the ability for hiv to
enter or not
into the cells so in order to probe
these
then surgery conducted contacted
volume that had just published
a nice flat flame probe that can allow
you to assess changes in membrane
tension
and you can see here uh an image on how
this works
so this actually uh changes the distance
between the
acceptor and the donor on the thread
probe depending on
how much uh changes in lipids
from order to on order lipids there are
in membrane
so then it is just a matter of
multiplexing so we have actually now
a cherry hiv
variant that can come into the membrane
interact with the receptor and core
receptor
and then if in the other side of the
membrane we have this mss probe
then we could actually tell what is the
tension at the membrane
and the spot where the environment can
fuse
the nice thing is that with these viral
particles
we can really tell the
timing of the hemi fusion port and
the operand of the fusion port and
have a correlation between the timing
when this happens
and whatever changes in membrane tension
we have
so again in this case we have m3 gag hiv
grfl for single wireless tracking and
in the other size side of
this experiment in the host site we'll
have the mss transfected
probe into these mdl cells
this allows to have all of the machinery
the receptors correctors of hiv but
also all of the reporter machinery that
we need to have this in a dynamic way
so uh some of the images look like so so
you have
the mss probe that you see here at the
membrane
and you can see that there is a
tiny hiv particle that has
attached to the membrane we can look
at the difference in time and then
follow this
across and then from this we can
actually
start measuring the lifetime changes and
the intensity changes and correlate what
happens
okay so uh the results look like so
so we have uh the changes in
m3 signal here in red so we can see
actually
that we have a point right here in which
the intensity starts to drop
substantially
this actually corresponds to the future
port opening
now we can see here two traces one
in green and one in gray the one
in green corresponds to the fluorescence
lifestyle
of the mss probe around this part where
we have
the m cherry signal so we're looking at
a colocalization
of signal between the virus particle and
the membrane
and the gray dots correspond to
the cell membrane all the same cells
but away from where the viral particle
is this allows us to see that there is
a substantial fluctuation on
membrane tension across
but it is interesting that subsequent to
the
fusion port opening we actually have a
stabilization
of a lower tension in
the membrane in the place where the
virus is
and this uh a significant
amount of time and corresponds to a
stabilization
of a low tension and then this
actually is recovered on top okay
this actually shows us that there are
local patient changes
that are happening exactly at the time
that
uh viral fusion is undergoing
now this is easily seen
in here and here actually we have uh
four experiments with their error bars
around it
and the first thing that we can see is
that there are local tension changes
during viral fusion that is the green
trace that you can see here
and exactly when hiv fusion is taking
place we have this drop
now uh in the uh
presence of two deoxy glucose oxygens
again
if you remember correctly this is when
the proportion of infection drops
actually we see then no change
in tension around the hiv particle
and the interesting thing is that
if we now treat with two deoxy glucose
but then we add cholesterol
then actually we restore this and drop
in tension
okay this uh completes
the story again i have obviously skipped
a lot of
other parts from the paper so again
please if this
uh spark your interest go and read the
paper
but it shows that first higher
metabolism
is uh more permissive to hiv-1
infection if you have an acute treatment
of two deoxychlucols
actually the percentage of infected
cells drops significantly
and when this happens actually one of
the changes that
is observed is the amount of cholesterol
the membrane
and this actually makes it the
fluidic parts of the membrane more or
less available for viral mp
now this correlates to the ability of
the h3 virus to
go from hemifusion to full fusion
basically in the case of low cholesterol
availability at the membrane
then most of the hiv
particles will stay at a direct
hemifusion state
and do not proceed to feel fusion
so all in all this allows us to have a
very nice
mechanistic view of the metabolism
of cells and the correlation that he has
with hiv infection
now let's switch gears a little bit more
and let's look a little bit at
some other work that we had here
and so uh just to recapitulate uh hiv
uh can enter either so we have cd4 it's
the
main receptor for hiv but then there is
uh of at least two core receptors that
can
uh be used by the virus one is ccr5 and
the other one is
cxcr4 so
this uh dependent of which kind of virus
you have you will use one
or the other one and uh
the strains really determine which one
it is
this also has an impact of where the
viral fuses either the plasma membrane
or adi
and the somo
fusion again this is recapitulated
really nicely
on the paper that maria
wrote as first author in the lab and i
invite you to
go have a read but in this case
what we want is to understand what are
the cellular mechanisms
that make this viral fission happen
okay so we know that uh receptor and
core receptors are needed
and then it will be really nice to be
able to actually
understand how they come together when
hiv
comes into play to create a fusion 4.
so in this case we use fluorescently
attack receptor and core receptor
and an attack hiv particle as well
and we're going to use single molecule
detection on the confocal volume
to exactly find out what is going on
at the molecular level here so
for these we use number and brightness
which
might not be very familiar to many
people
but this was originally worked
out by enrico graton and michel diekmann
in 2008 at the lfd and
the reference is here if you want to
find out more about it the principle is
quite
straightforward it means that if you
have a
focal volume here and you see particles
inside that are green
and there are six of them if the six of
them
are individual molecules then you have a
certain
average over time
now if you see if the same six
particles actually come and now are
dimers so now you have three dimers
all six molecules the average intensity
will
remain the same but the amplitude of the
flux of the fluctuations
will differ this is what we see here the
frequency
of uh the dimers compared to the
monomers
is different and when looking at this
this is how we can actually tell the
oligomeric state
of individual molecules coming into our
focal volume
now for these to be applicable to
our hiv research we had to do some work
and this can be found in a couple papers
and one is a new algorithm for
dealing with the traces that you get out
of this
publish in 2017 bioinformatics and the
other one
is a guide on how to implement numbering
brightness is basically
everything i would have liked to know
when we started the project and that we
found out
to make this project happen again if
you're interested
on applying these advanced imaging
techniques
this is a good starting point and
uh just to make a long story short
this is what we did with hiv so we have
actually
a receptor and core receptor here in
green and blue traces
and we're going to look at across
variance to see
if there's interaction between the
receptor and the core receptor at the
same time
on a third channel we're going to track
the virus and then we're going to see
if we have interaction between uh cd4
and
ccr5 for example that is positive
then we see if that collocalizes with
the
virus particle and if that is the case
then we can go back
and look at the algorithmic state of
each one of them
and this will allow us to build up the
time resolve stoichiometry of the whole
thing
and we can do that dynamically through
time
it looks like so here we only have time
zero and
time 1.7 minutes and you can see that we
are
chasing a viral particle in this insert
in cyan
you can see when we actually see of our
particle and then
exactly in the same area we will
actually in the
right and the left side
far left we have the ccr4
signal and the cd4 signal
now as time goes by this evolves and
then suddenly we start having a positive
uh cross-correlation uh that is shows up
here in green in the insert
this means that cd4 and cs
xcr4 are interacting and then
we can go back in the brightnesses and
actually get the oligomeric
states this allows us to build this
graph here
in which we have uh on time the
oligomeric state of each one
the receptor and the core receptor and
we know that they're both interacting
at the same time the nice thing is that
we can redo this experiment and add a
neutralizing antibody as well
and when we do so actually what we see
is that
first there is no interaction between
cd4 and cxcr4
and also the complete stigmatary
of receptor encore receptor has changed
so all of these immersion experiments uh
what allows us to do is to go back into
the literature
and start understanding what is
happening dynamically
for all of the structures of hiv over
time
so this graph that i just showed you
can be represented like we see here
in the right side in three steps step
one
in which the envelope from hiv actually
hooks into a cd4
and in this step these recruitment of
cd4 by the envelope
actually recruits cxcr4 as a dimer
the xcr4 is a gpcr so this actually
triggers
signaling from the core receptor down
and this actually uh goes into
six cd4s and
two cxe of fourth formation
two of them is assembled trading and
anchoring domain
that then goes into fusion
so you can see how actually having all
of these steps
with the number of molecules at each one
of these data and knowing that
they have a correlation together allow
us to
build a complete view of the first seven
minutes
of the fusion formation
in a similar way with a different
tropism
with grfl variants then we can actually
look at
the what happens with cd4 and ccr5
and we see that actually there are still
three steps
but they are slightly different and i
just wanted
to point out here these are the pdp
entries of all of these structures that
have been known obviously cryo
electron microscopy structures cryo
structures or
classical
crystallography structures are not
dynamic
and you only get a specific voltage in
time
and you can have only that view and we
can see that
now because we can see the whole
circuitry of the reaction we can
actually plug in
all of the different structural views
that have been observed to date into a
comprehensive model
and make sense of the whole dynamics
here
as i mentioned before we can do this
also with
the neutralizing antibodies such as b12
here
and then this allows us to build a
dynamic model of
when this inhibition is happening and to
what epitopes
so we can really understand the temporal
mechanisms of these antibodies
and this method could allow us to
determine which antibodies
can actually work synergistically
together because
if you have uh inhibition of say
step one but not two and then you have a
different neutralization antibody that
can neutralize step three
but not one then you would expect that
actually working together you will have
a more significant strong effect
to hiv entry this will be very helpful
for vaccine design and actually
certainly
has been awarded an erc consolidator
grant to continue
these studies and the title of this
project is simple molecule
engine based design of hiv vaccines
so i'm going to finish on this note and
i hope that
you have seen the value of what
quantitative advance imaging can do on
bioresearch
we can really multiplex the different
aspects of
cellular signaling changes in metabolism
and so forth with
the aspects of viral entry this is also
possible with viral aggress
and older aspects of the viral infection
process
in addition to that i
hope that you have seen the powerful
tools that allows us to have a really
really nice detailed view
on each one of the steps of the dynamic
process
of hiv infection i wanted to point out
this because as
all biology is dynamic uh having a
complete
view of when the infection starts and
how he proceeds can really open new
views
on how we can intervene where we can
intervene
and perhaps have some
newer ideas of targets and epitopes that
we can
study to have other inhibitors or
new vaccines for this i'm going to
finish with thanking
people that make this work possible
more importantly to sergey and that led
the lab and that
allowed me to learn a lot from him and
work on these exciting projects while i
was in oxford
he has now moved to king's college uh i
have
put it uh the website of his lab if
you're interested in contacting him
but also to uh now dr rory nolan he was
a phd student
and there and he is responsible for all
of the
mathematics that allows us to do
normal brightness
aro maria that actually did all of this
a lot of work for our
structural paper and
[Music]
the other people around in oxford uh
professor thomas bowden
and michael dawson for their help in all
of this work
now i want to thank you all of you for
your attention
and i would like to open it up for
questions
dr alvarez thank you for that excellent
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
now to our audience if you have any
questions you would like to ask
if you haven't already done so please do
so now we have lots of questions already
coming in
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so dr alvarez let's start with this one
and this one is two parts
how would you visualize single viral
particles
without fluorescence tagged viruses
for example sars or kobe 2
and would anti-spike antibodies staining
be sufficient to quantitate viral
particles either with an sp8 or a stead
uh well again thank you everyone for
listening and
again i just want to point out this a
lot of great work that we did in oxford
so uh you can obviously visualize viral
viral particles if you are not able to
generally intact them
uh it always depends on the question
you're trying to answer
so if what you want to see is the
dynamics of
viral entry for example it is possible
to actually
label them with lipophilic dyes
and this is actually quite nice because
you can actually track a particle and
then
as soon as it hits uh the cellular
membrane
what you would see is a spiking
fluorescence when actually the
uh the dyes actually get diluted into
the cell so you can have
the exact timing of opening the pore
from a heavy fusion
that is one option now the other one
is related to the antibodies so yes you
can visualize
viral particles with antibodies but not
dynamically because
most antibodies will actually prevent
infection from happening
and but what you can do in this case is
that you can
[Music]
do the infections and then do fixations
at different time points and then
you can use antibodies it is not
straightforward to do but
it is possible to actually do a
quantification
in this regard and we were actually
asked
to do a number of super resolution
experiments to validate
our dynamic number and brightness uh
studies so in the
uh natural structural molecular biology
paper there are some strategies to do
exactly this so it is possible with
antibodies
we use actually nanobodies and
it's it's possible it's a little bit
more difficult you need to understand
where the antibodies binding and you
need to have some controls
thank you dr alvarez now our next
question
to what extent do you have to minimize
the amount of sp expression
with gag and envy fusion
to preserve maturation and infectivity
is one protein more tolerant than the
other
okay so uh these uh
first thing is they're not comparable at
all so on the gag
is uh relatively well known and
uh usually you don't want to have more
than 50 percent of the gut protein stuck
otherwise you actually end up with the
percentage of immature viruses actually
increases
once you cross that threshold
now on the spikes it is much more
complicated because you have to take
into account that
each one of these spikes is a primer
that needs to actually lock into a
specific position to be
infections and so uh the
the work that i cited actually is quite
good and looking at this and
the ones that you can use and in this
case
uh i will just follow exactly the paper
from matsuda
and uh you have to do to your controls
but
in this case uh tagging actually the
spikes of any virus
so any uh glycoprop envelope
glycoprotein
is going to be much more delicate than
uh internal proteins such as gag
thank you dr alvarez your eyeblam data
it looks like more green cells rather
than reduction in
infection can you comment on that
well uh again when you're looking at
iblom data what you want to do is a
statistical analysis and so you take the
overall number of cells and then you
compare actually proportion on
on the infection versus non-infected and
this is the only way that you can
actually
assess whether there is a reduction or
not because it's the overall percentage
of infected cells from the whole
population
so what you saw there is just one field
but obviously
the data does not come from a single
field of microscopy
can this technology be used to identify
unknown viral receptors
no so
this technology is uh used to
study the psychometry the mechanisms so
uh the problem with unknown receptors is
that you need to
identify them um and how would you be
able to trace back
which receptor is the one doing this
work
so what you can do is without knowing
the receptor you can study actually
uh the changes at the membrane for
example the changes in tensions and all
that
and know that uh a different kind of
virus or different strains or different
cells
behave differently these you could do
but it will be impossible to actually
know
which is the receptor that is
responsible for it for
uh tracking which receptors are needed
actually you need to
have different kind of technologies and
you need to be able to have some
sequencing
even either have a set of
cells that have different mutations and
different receptors and you can see
which ones are the ones that
are effective and are permissible to
infection and which ones are not
this is one option the other option is
actually uh
to uh do some fixation experiments in
which you actually
uh get a virus onto cells
and then the ones that actually can look
unlock into cells
then actually have some strategies to
cross link
the virus to whatever receptor is on top
of the membrane
and if you have these enough times you
could actually
do some uh mass like experiments out of
these
and actually get the peptide sequences
that corresponds to the unknown
receptors and from there go to a library
and identified the receptors that could
match this
but this is a different kind of work
dr alvarez thank you so much for this q
a session unfortunately we are out of
time and unable to take any more live
questions i do want to encourage our
audience there were so many questions
that came in that we are unable to
answer
these questions will be answered via
email to the email
address that you provided when you
registered for today's webinar
today's webinar can be viewed on demand
and lab routes will send you an email
following this webinar when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event one big big
thank you to dr louise alvarez for his
time today and his important research
thank you also to leica microsystems for
sponsoring today's event
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon
have a great day